You know the central keep shining. The window keep blowing. The rain will keep falling. These are all things that the.
Keep happening for as long as there's life on earth you know that we don't. We don't need to have these insane.
Power systems that pollute the planet. And require lots of maintenance and stuff anymore you know the.
Technology is there today. To provide power at one's fingertips.
Without having to having to flog one's guts out in order to maintain the systems. Well back in the seventy's.
Or even further back in the sixty's a lot of people like myself.
Held these views of the world as it was not being able to sustain itself very much longer.
A lot of other people in mainstream society would say oh the reason these crazy stupid ideas you know.
They were to come back to reality and see what it's all about but. It's amazing over the last twenty years here.
And how people's. Acceptance of. The fact that we can't keep on going the way we were has changed. Now.
Where i was an extremist. Twenty years ago. Now my ideas are accepted everywhere.
You know so i think there's been some amazing changes there. The problem is that although.
People are all aware of what the shortcomings of. Of society as it as it stands.
Still not very many people are really prepared to change their own life.
You know they all agree with the fact that something needs to be done. But there.
Most people seem to be waiting for somebody else to lead the way.
And i guess that's what the rain
but there are companies about as we're trying to say look it's all here it's all available.
When she just all do it now you know.
And unfortunately one of the obstacles that we're still against at the moment is that. In this city.
Suburban environment. You know power systems are not cost competitive with a grid system.
They would be a lot more cost compared if the grid system.
Was incorporated or the real costs of the system which i don't. But anyway. We as.
Cost competitive in the rural environment.
It's a pity that we're not the cost competitive yet in the city environment i guess that's just only a matter of time.
Even even with the cross subsidise ation of systems the way they are today.
If that doesn't change we were still become cost competitive in the next decade or so.
Just because technology is improving and. Renewable energy system to get improving all the time around products.
You know they're aimed at power company products that we have for sale include.
The micro hydro system and when i was telling you there. We also developed a sine wave inverter.
An inverter is something that gives you a high voltage a seat like two forty volts ac from better we supply.
Most inverters that. Vailable. The nowness. Modified square or stepdaughter square wave and.
The problem with with those way forms out of the inverters is a lot of standard to forgive all equipment doesn't like
it. And we felt that there was a great need. In america place for a sine wave.
We went and developed their own sign maven the. Which turns out to be a very. Indestructible product.
It's we believe it's one of the best inverters in the mcas and. Any equipment.
Within the worth integrating of the invertible. Will run very happily off it.
We're now in the process of making a large inverter the one that we had so if there was a three hundred what.
Twelve often the. When they are developing a six hundred word. Inverted it's also got some other added features.
It will actually reverse is a better judge as well. And we believe it's going to be a lot more efficient and.
In the small than the it is. Yeah. It's. I always like to keep systems as simple as possible and.
With that in mind it seems a lot more sensible if you have a better bank.
To have things that run directly off the battery bank.
Then to have things standard to forgive all appliances for which you need an inverter.
The problem is that the same or different pieces of equipment and people might want to have some of them.
Probably very difficult if not impossible to obtain as a d.c.
Appliance and we're not in the business of trying to think of every possible appliance
and making an alternative available. We tell people about the alternatives that we know about.
And occasionally some of the more popular products will actually go out of her way to try and either.
Source an alternative. One or many thanks one ourselves but. We are mainly about setting up our systems another bit.
Supplying the appliances as well. What we usually recommend to people is to have. D.c.
Lighting as much as possible and. Use d.c. Appliances wherever possible. That we're where. D.c.
Appliances and available. Then you probably just get your stand ac appliance and run it. Via an inverter.
So then we wanted to make an inverter available. That will give the minimum of. Problem with running these appliances.
We have had problems with. D.c. Appliances in the past. Every once in a while we come across a really good.
Twelve volt appliance.
And we start selling it in six months
or a year down the track we discover that the people that are doing the importing will manifest in that particular
appliance don't feel. There's a big enough market place.
Not selling enough of them and they decide to discontinue it even though there were.
We were doing really well with them. So that's unfortunate. But i guess air power systems.
Will be as dependable as what we you know if i don't say the company is going to go down and you go over it all.
It's actually quite amazing you know where.
Other small businesses have staggered in the forward probably ninety percent of business is a bit in your recent years
the status of the. Forward bit in a year or so.
Here we're growing at a phenomenal rate and not seeing any end of the growth rate. You know just goes on and.
So the way things are looking i could see that. The rain that they're here in is here to stay and.
We're going to get bigger and bigger. Structure here. Yeah. And i kist think i guess. I mean. It's interesting.
There were identical years off and same to total chaos. You know but yet.
If you look at the way we're running here or even or there were either all chiefs
or all indians nobody really knows worth. We've got a working relationship here that really does work. You know.
We all know who to see about what and who to communicate with and. It all seems to happen next. Exceptionally well.
As i was saying we've got a structure whereby we don't have a pyramid structure at all. Everybody's on the same level.
We're all in the same wage.
No matter what you do have an equal opportunity and having some say in what goes on in the company. So i guess.
I guess one of the things that makes it work is the. That we lift with the responsibility.
Each one of us has got the responsibility you know it's not. We can't pass a responsibility on to somebody else.
I guess take the attitude that each and every one of us is bit like a foreman.
You know we've got to make sure the job is done and the job is done properly.
In effect that we are all shareholders we're all proud owners of the company gives us a very direct interest in what
goes on with a company. Well i don't know. I guess. We're all really proud of the company.
You know we really like what we're doing and we we all have great regard for each other.
I was thinking certainly i mean again. But you know it's got be busier than cancer. Gives you question again.
Well i think. We have an incentive here. You can say. Nobody's going to get rich but i guess.
Prosperous the company prospers all together. You know at the moment.
We're getting very low wage rates just because we can't afford to increase of wage rates as yet
but hopefully in the near future will be able to increase it
and as a company prosperous their wage rates will an increase in altogether. The fact that we know that there's no.
Not somebody. Amongst us to make an enormous amount of profit.
And second forcing everybody else makes us feel much happy and then we know that. We're all equal.
And it's quite amazing how we. Was the level of commitment within the company is actually quite the standing. You know.
If you look at other companies and you look at the staff turnover. We've been going for for four years.
And their staff turnover is incredibly low. You know. Most people that come and join us here this day.
You know they're happy here and not really came to move on a new or else. I know from a self. That.
I've worked at all sorts of jobs in my life
and most of those jobs i didn't really win the nobel i wasn't happy with them. You know.
And pat pat the reason for not being happy with those jobs because they were damaged in the environment.
And the thank that i knew i was doing a job that was destructive. Didn't make me feel good. You know.
And the fact that i was working for a boss no i didn't have. Have any chance of.
Steering the company in different direction or anything just made me lose interest in it.
You know whereas i think the way we've set up this company here. Is every incentive for people to speak up.
To be involved.
People can feel good about it because because we are doing something that we believe is good for the environment.
We're about sitting there. Creating change in public awareness and creating change in. Stan.
I was going to talk about standards of living. You know creating a change in the lifestyle.
You know the thing about standard of living is that. It's often quite meaningless you know what really matters to us.
Is quality of life. You know the fact that you've got. Toilet paper with with pretty flowers printed on it. You know.
It does not improve one's quality of life but. That is seen to improve the standard of living you know.
The idea of stand of living it's quite nonsensical. Oh i think my quality of life is probably very high.
I mean i don't know. Nobody is going around sort of. Comparing people's quality of life that i know of.
But although there is a lot of study being done on standard of living
and standards of living a based entirely on the profit and turnover norm that's still the stuff that doesn't.
You know people can be totally miserable. Caught up in the rat race doing a job they don't like. And yet.
Their standard of living can be seen to be very high you know but but their quality of life is just down the drain.
And the way that. We are here i think that we're all. As i was saying before we don't do any very much.
But we're living in a rural environment. We've got clean air fresh water and this. Beautiful views.
We can do what we won't we are all free individuals we're not working on the buses.
We're getting basically what we need. And i think that makes a quality of life very high. You know.
Even though there's somebody might say i stand of living is not so high. Yeah.
As you can see we've got there are lines only fifty meters away. But we decided. When we built this place that.
This is the rain that new rain that their company premises that we were not going to connect to the grid.
And we were going to provide all their own pay for it and. Down by way of. Bet fifty solar panels on the roof.
And their winter at the back and a standby generator if neither of those work or. This building is also. Incorporating.
Passive solar design. We've got most of the glass. Facing north. Being in the seventy m. C. Of the. Sense joins in.
You know this is from the north. We've got eaves over or these windows.
Calculated to let the sun shine in over the winter months. But to keep the sending out over the summer months.
This building is a severe story ended. So that you know we've got a lot of thermal mass in the building.
We've got six hundred tons of mud brick in the building i think and concrete floors.
So that when the scent penetrates into the building over the winter months. All that thermal mess heats up and.
Maintains its heat for a long period of time so the building tends to retain its heat over the winter months.
Over the summer months as sam doesn't shine in so all this there were mistakes relatively cool and.
Keeps a fairly constant cool temperature over the summer months.
We've also got a fairly high roof in the building which allows us to use lies to some extent. We call it.
The chimney effect. You know thermal updrafts.
So that it's possible to open up areas of the building where the cool air can be allowed in.
And as the air heats up it moves out through through the vents in the roof. Those vents in the roof can be closed off.
So that. In the winter months you can maintain the heat within the beginning of the summer months you can just.
They are the airflow to keep building cool. We've got they think you've seen the courtyard.
We've got a courtyard within the building totally surrounded by the building which is got no roof.
So it's an open area but within the building.
And that helps to let more light into the building because of the size of the building.
And also a way i was to ventilate the building. More adequately.
Nimbleness as the alternative keppel of the strayer i think niman is a very unique place and.
Nimitz uniqueness is lend itself to sitting up with the rain but there are company here.
A lot more successfully than we could have done anywhere else in the country.
Nimbin is famous for being famous so to speak. You know. We keep getting media.
Being attracted here all the time and most of the time.
They've so the forgotten why they're coming here but i just don't keep coming here.
And i think that that has helped us to a great extent. You know.
We've got in this area we have a lot of really committed people. People with great environmental awareness and.
People who are really keen on the trying out new experiments.
I think that looking for people with those qualities yasir in the country would be a lot had and in and in the area.
We've got every. Would you call it. Skill you could possibly think of.
Within a twenty mile radius of newman you know so you can think of.
You probably don't have to go very far to find it you know i know of people around here that.
Were a nuclear physicist etc you know. I just didn't want to be padded anymore so i decided to come to an inventor.
So i think that. Nimbin. Does attract the kind of people that helps to make their aim at their company work. Yeah.
Yeah there is definitely. Year. Your name and again. Name is very unusual in many respects.
Even though they're let's say we're in a site here that's not all that good for insulation for solitaire.
Yet nimbin is probably at of all the residents nimbin more than fifty percent of them are living on their own
standalone power systems. And most of those are living on the. Entirely solar power systems.
So there's a very strong awareness. In this area of environmental issues in a lot of people that. Move here.
Do not want to know that they're.
Also people who do not want to know
or they are a bad standard to carry a serious systems in all sorts of stuff we've had a great dispute in in business
recently over the name and sewerage game. You know a lot of the townsfolk wanted it. Very much. I think.
Through ignorance. You know.
Because it's a funny thing the sirius system because it's only been around for a hundred years you know there were the
karyotype sewerage system but.
Yet this day
and age it's taken for granted you know if you want a serious system with a carry siri system is the only way to go.
And unfortunately the strategy has been very few. Down set up within you know anything else. So there's no other.
Example for people to turn to. So when. There was a lot of talk in him in the bed. Having a sewage system here.
So many people said oh yeah ok. We'll carry sewage system. Because that's what everybody immediately thinks of.
What a lot of the the. People do not live in the township. They live in the surrounding areas.
And most of these people do not like to see the war they carry a serious system. You know and particularly.
Now we've been hearing so much lately. They are blue green algae pollution of. River systems and.
Ocean pollution through ocean outfalls and that's the stuff.
And also you have a strategy it's generally a very dry continent. And just same scrape.
Added our top quality that we should be flushing thirty five to fifty percent of it down the downy. You know.
We hear the rain but our company we decided to go for a dry composting toilet.
You know so you're not you not flushing the down your door there's no water involved in the process. We also.
Self-sufficient with water here. Or the water requirements for the rain that their company collected off the roof here.
We don't do not connect to the nimbin. The supply system being you a going back to what i was talking about.
With with the sirius system in him and. I think that there were other options there.
Particularly one option that would have been very very much cheaper.
To this sewage game that's now going in the game is costing about three million dollars. We could have put in.
Drug companies. Posting to of this nature. For a fraction of that cost.
And then of course no further bills or anything down the line other than just. Just a small collection fee.
You know i think that every six months
or possibly an employee of their aimed at their company even could have just gone around
and emptied the filled containers. You know the thing about dry composting toilet is what comes out of him.
Is not in any way unpleasant. It's what comes out of his actually very rich. Soft soil.
You know humus it's a very dry crumbly soft soil it's. It's actually.
It's no different to the best saw that you find in the garden and you're you know if you wait.
If you've got a dry composition toil and it's hard to decay for at least nine months then.
Then what you've got to deal with there is actually a very valuable commodity.
It's actually a saleable commodity whereas what we're doing now.
I'm not sure where they were they thinking about trying to sell. The byproduct.
But the problem with with their standard oil carry serious systems is that the byproduct.
Is still likely to be contaminated with with all sorts of human pathogens. Whereas with a dry composting toilet.
Every human pathogen. Other than possibly around will make has been destroyed in the process.
So there's nothing that compares with with with dry composting for getting rid of pathogens.
If you must get frustrated. Things like well. Well if you ask around him been there as a success story.
I think everybody will point to the name that their company first thing you know. I think that.
There are things happening. Around nimbin.
That everybody is proud of the way that i feel about things i thought i've had this feeling for a long long time i
remember when i was a teenager in my twenty's
and seeing all these demonstrations around the place you know vietnam demonstrations all this is stuff.
And all these demonstrations to me. Seem to be wrong. They seem to be throwing aggression. At violence. You know.
Throwing more violence in the direction of violence. To me if you wanted to demonstrate something.
What you ought to be demonstrating is how to do it. Not him not to do it. You know.
I guess that's what my life has been all about.
You know i've always wanted to demonstrate the positive and not the negative.
So they're aimed at their company is an example of that. I think that with through here trying to demonstrate.
Not necessarily what's wrong with their with where the us is doing it. But they have to do it correctly and.
I think that. You know. Nimbin. Got all sorts of. Positive and negative aspects to it.
But i'd like to focus more on the positive and not take so much notice of the negative. Hence our address year.
One alternative way. We had a straight here that never name to it so decide to give their own name. And that's are ok.